so the Netflix special it's out how long
does it take you to work on this NE on
on the next show yeah you need some
stuff to happen to you right do you need
me to like shoot you in the shoulder
which would give that would be like a
good 20 minutes let head to Urban Air
yeah do you need me to shoot you in the
shoulder I mean can you imagine that's
that's when Conan said to me do you need
me to shoot you in the shoulder and
sure sure Conan is funny sometimes but
this was a time where it didn't seem
like was making a
joke I would use a 22 I would use I
would use a lower caliber you would kill
him you're like you're a marksman but
you're you you don't shoot you go
shooting you're going to kill him which
what oh 50/50 chance he gets killed but
you get a ton of material out of it and
then I come on at the end of the show
and we hug that's a big show by the way
that's another that's another handoff
that I think that we could pull off and
2024 is if you end up cuz you were
talking about going out and doing a
whole bunch of live dates maybe even
standup right if you do that I want to
pop into some of those shows I would
love to have you do that I would love it
well you're saying that now my dream
would it
Conan all the jokes aside oh
no and you have to deal with this all
the time this is the bane of your
existence there's a generation of us
comedians who view you as the Buddha of
Comedy oh wow okay all right well you're
old and and apparently
fat I'm apparently fat yeah and old I'm
sorry I ruined it no you actually son
Sona you that was exactly what I need on
my way in gave me a compliment and cuz
I've known Paula forever since your late
night Paula's been with me 30 years yeah
and she gave gave me a compliment and
and I and I basically said you know if
you stick around long enough in Show
Business eventually they let you just
stay and she goes you and Conan are the
best at batting away
compliments yeah but you are you're the
you know thank you very much yeah that
would be that would be I don't it
doesn't process I you know what you know
what's nice you know it does process for
me I I um I don't take it for granted
that like seeing you last night and
Jimmy and Jesus Christ Marty Short who
is uh is funny in a way that always
makes me question like how can anybody
be that funny in so many ways uh I uh
but just to to to like run into you guys
and just
be joking around and then on the ride
home realize that I get I get to like I
don't know get to be around all these
very funny people who are really
creative
it's nice what a what a what a
this is how this is how much I idolize
Martin sh to wear at dinner and I don't
eat onions or tomatoes mhm um and you
went to an Italian restaurant and I get
mocked I get mocked by my family
including my daughter and eight-year-old
daughter because she eats more stuff
than I do but with Marty Short I'm like
I'm just going full onions tomatoes you
know what I mean I'm just I can't I
can't be that person well also there's a
moment where you realize you've made a
mistake around Martin Short because he
is you know when you walk if you're in a
museum or something and every and you're
and you're in a room alone and you're
really still and then you move slightly
a little red light goes up those motion
sensors and the red light's just going
to register movement and they can pick
up the slightest movement Marty Short is
one of those for someone making a
mistake yeah the smallest mistake and I
I think I've mentioned this but I have
to mention it again which is on one of
the last uh late night shows I did a
couple years a two years ago um I'm
driving to a rehearsal in Marty Short
which was my dream agreed to come on and
do this bit where he sings a song to me
at the end about how I'm always been the
only one like for him that kind of bet
Midler Johnny Carson tribute song and
then I reveal to him that he's actually
sung this to
uh he did it for Letterman when he went
off the air and then he did it for all
these other people and we Marty Short
shot all these oh yeah yeah great
pre-tapes and we said you did it on when
Springer ended and there's a huge and we
could we could put him into all these
you did it uh when they when they
retired um the shamrock shake at at at
McDonald's or something we did it we put
it into so many ways that he had done it
anyway that was the bit and it was a
really hot day and I never wear shorts
and this day just threw on some like
cargo shorts that were above the knee
and I'm driving in to the Largo theater
to tape the last show and I
thought oh yeah I'm wearing shorts today
well I never wear shorts people might
give me a hard time it'll be fine and
then I suddenly remembered I thought
wait who's on the show today and I
remembered it was Martin Short and my
heart stopped I was in the car on lasena
and I like oh and sure enough I'm
in there rehearsal and the double doors
open up and Marty comes in and he's like
hello all and everyone's like Yay Martin
Short we're just going to rehearse and
he goes ah young Conan and he he wearing
shorts and then he did maybe 20 minutes
yeah of pure destruction and humil and
it was fantastic and of course my
everyone who works for me was crying
laughing so hard yeah know he there's a
few people like that bill haters like
that y where you have to be aware that
whatever you're saying or doing is being
clocked uh with a deep sensitivity he he
does an impression of me that's so cruel
that my wife Jenny loves which is this
the whole impression he
goes but it was my
car that's the whole
impression it's nothing that I say
it's nothing I've said in any joke but
it was my car bill is just beyond he's
on another planet yeah of funny but also
just knowing that uh you're you're
around these people who have a
superpower that that they'll notice
something the slightest yeah the slight
I misspoke slightly or I had this little
tick and they're like ah delicious
you're like that yeah you are like that
not at all anyway moving on um not at
all not at all and I love you both no
but I I value that too like I feel so
lucky like I my first taste of that in
addition to like my own family like
you're saying was when I got to college
and I and I was like is there a sketch
comedy group because I wanted to write
comedy like on late night and uh they
said there isn't but there's an improv
group I I I don't know what that is and
I audition I got in and when I got in I
was like oh these are 10 people who are
like that who are just like we're going
to make fun of everything we're going to
do impressions of everything we're going
to be very annoying but also kind of
amazing and those are like some of my
closest friends to this day I've always
thought and this goes for everybody here
like isn't I was I always tell my kids
that the journey is finding your people
like that's the journey the journey is
uh there's there's little there there it
it's you you set off into the world and
then it's just collecting people that
you know inspire you whatever charge you
in some way and then at the end it is
like one of those movies those travel
log movies where the person heads out in
the beginning and at the end they've got
like this this group of people that have
different powers but they've befriended
them along the way I don't know I I
which brings me to my final point which
is that Conan and I have finally found
each other oh and cods is going to be a
huge success love I don't know I don't
know no these are do mean you don't know
I just crank out these pods man one bag
of dust their cost to ratio I mean it's
incredible huge in Brazil these are huge
in Brazil look I'm fine with him taking
a dive on that I feel like I don't want
you that's a joint venture yeah joint
venture meeting you put up most the cash
I put up 90% of the money oh no and
incur most of the risk
yeah yeah yeah no I say no don't all
right well Buddha is not taking a risk
over
here Buddha is sitting on his fat
ass I'm gonna start using that I'm
Buddha that's not something Buddha would
say